yeah can you just tie it down a little
yeah i'm trying to make a oh i'm just
hanging out with all my friends in
the club hello everyone i'm alana
welcome to my channel where i'm doing
another q a that i'm supposed to be
doing on the first friday of every month
but then i realized
because i upload my podcast on the first
friday of every month
things are like sort of it seems weird
to do that so i'm not doing it on a
friday
but close to skelzor17
nope that was 17 minutes ago he does not
have 17 in his title uh ask what is your
natural hair color ever since i've been
watching your channel you've been silver
it looks great though
um yeah i got some comments on my hair
dye tutorial
ish video uh saying they thought my hair
was black
definitely not it's well
i would say it's like a very light brown
a little bit blondish i don't know
brown irish fist said thoughts on game
pass
is it not objectively good does anyone
not support
game pass it's good reagan
evil maybe rage and evil
uh said how accessible is gaming
journalism as a career for someone
wanting to change careers at 30.
very accessible but potentially not that
profitable because it was not that
profitable for me
anyway despite what most people think i
did not make very much money at ign
um but you can make more money if you
work on camera
uh whereas the just actual journalism
side of things which is generally
reporting of information
or uh writing a feature counts as
journalism frankly even youtube does
actually
technically fall under the branch of
journalism but it depends which part of
it you want to do basically um and how
you could sustain yourself but i would
suggest to anyone who wants to try it i
don't think there's an age limit
it just isn't necessarily going to
become lucrative for you unless you have
a lot of
uh spare time to devote to getting your
resume and your skill set up
uh very significantly by the time that i
applied for a job at ign i already had
worked for maybe 30 outlets it was
pretty tremendous
and obviously um the way i was able to
do that was in very significant part
because uh i was a lot younger i was
still living at home my
family was helping me financially when i
was going to events or whatever so it
depends how aggressively you want to get
into it but there's nothing to stop you
from
literally right now putting together a
freelance um
article or a pitch and finding the pitch
email addresses of any of the major
websites and literally pitching it to
them and getting paid for it you could
do that
literally right now getting into the
industry definitely requires a large
time commitment
for some people i also know some dudes
who literally just like
met someone and then got a job the next
day so
i don't know yes i think you should try
it if you want to do it there's nothing
stopping you at all
james fristic said what makes alana mad
truth be told it is very difficult to
anger me i do not get angry um
definitely not at the expense of myself
very often
i get angry if someone mistreats someone
i care about
that is one thing that'll make me really
mad i also get angry at those instagram
accounts
where they have a very cute dog that
they post pictures of but in the
captions they role play
as the dog like they're like oh i am
hungry today uh
mum gave me the treats
you could just be a human posting about
your dog why
it ruins the whole dog i i've sometimes
had dog accounts like slide into my dms
and one of the dog accounts that i
followed was a very cute dog tried to
hit on me
and posted like a lipstick emoji asking
if i wanted some implying
like a dog's p like what
corner couch said what has been your
go-to game these last few weeks of
quarantine
if you couldn't tell animal crossing has
been a lot of my
life lately i've played a little bit of
valorant though
probably maybe five hours or so total so
it's not a ton but i have [ __ ] with it
a bit
and um been consuming plenty of final
fantasy vii john priyano said i know
that you've already answered this
question in the video but since three
weeks have passed with all the
chronovirus thing going on i was
wondering if you were all right
i'm doing pretty good all things
considered certainly having
regular human struggles but for the most
part um
yeah i'm coping pretty well uh he also
said besides that
what inspires you to keep uploading
content as good as you do
well firstly thank you but uh i just
really like creating stuff i really like
making stuff
i feel like i'm not
living correctly if i'm not constantly
creating it's sort of a
unhealthy vice almost that i feel like i
constantly have to be out putting
stuff or i just feel inadequate
it's not like a wholesome inspiration
it's like a need
i just really like feeling productive
it's very important to me phil carey
said you think playstation will hold its
lead in the next in the console market
or is next generation going to belong to
series x
listen phil listen i just
don't care it's a valid question for you
to ask someone in my position i
understand i'm sorry
i just don't care about console wars or
who is on top of these
billion dollar corporations
you know but i also think you know we're
not that far away from
streaming being the future of even
video games um people will definitely
argue that with me of course because a
lot of the world doesn't have stable
enough internet connections and a lot of
them are falling apart but i think
that's probably the direction that they
are actually realistically shifting in
i don't know that console wasn't gonna
last forever we will have streaming wars
just like we do now for film and tv
curly host what are you doing for a
workout routine and quarantine i've
definitely fallen on the wagon a bit
since the gym closed and it's been
raining constantly here uh i too have
not been doing a great job trying to
improve it this week specifically i'm
getting
getting back there um i'm just lifting
weights and i'm intending to play
a bunch more um like vr games for cardio
because obviously it's not easy to go
out right now
so stuff like beat saber even super hot
can be a really good workout
um but if you don't have vr obviously
that's hard to access but just lift and
heavy stuff if you don't have weights
you can put a bunch of books in a bag
and that will work effectively the same
it's better than doing nothing
because at least you can get yourself
moving you know uh rhys willoughby said
what characters would you be interested
in cosplaying that you haven't done
before
you know i think i answered this in like
my second ever q a which would have been
five years ago maybe my number one
cosplay that i would always want to do
is tyriel from diablo
it's just so cool i don't have the
skills to make that or the time to make
that but
i've always loved that character design
so much
michael asked do you have one of the
most active subreddits i've ever seen
with 10
000 subscribers why do you seem to
ignore it
um no it's definitely not that that's
something that i ignore i mean if
someone were to
tag me in something and ask a question i
would i would answer it um
i spent a lot of time on the fun house
subreddit in any case because of that
community
uh the subreddit that that was made for
me
um for a really long time was
unmoderated and just like very gross and
it didn't actually feel like it was
there for me to be a part of like it
felt like
other people wanted that to talk about
me but they did not actually want me
as a part of that community um i feel
like that's probably still the case
uh because i didn't make it i didn't
shut it down most people in my position
would have shut that down but i was like
no i'll let you have this but
it wasn't made for me it is now
moderated so
i don't think it's creepy anymore since
that moderator started i had to be fair
i have not uh actively frequently
checked for a while
but that is is really the main reason is
i don't feel like that subreddit exists
for me to be there it exists for it to
be about me
and i know that it's odd that i'm like
completely okay with that but i am like
have you enjoy but i believe it is also
they just repost the content that i have
on other places so i would prefer to you
know reply to comments on my own youtube
channel or on my own instagram or on my
own twitter
uh rather than go to a completely
separate website that i don't run to do
that because that's not even really
necessarily my community who are
actually following me so
this is not something that's sinister or
um or dramatic
in the way i feel like this question was
maybe asked maybe i'm reading into that
too much
but it's generally just not mine i don't
run it
it's not for me it's not at me
if you like to ask me a question on
reddit i do answer stuff on there pretty
readily
uh you just have to at me as a user in a
thread
and i'll engage in conversation
anytime theresa t said hi elena have you
ever told fiona that she kind of has
dodgy cat vibes because not to be horny
on mean but hot damn also what's up she
definitely does i have not told her that
i
actually just recorded a gameplay of
valorent with fiona and i was like a
little bit nervous
before we started recording because i
have a little bit of a crush on her and
i wasn't like
sure like how much i should make that
obvious or how cool i should play it or
like what i should do
you know about her being there and being
hot and that
so i just you know acted like i didn't
give a [ __ ] we'll see if it worked
but i genuinely did have to think about
it before that started
jeff mccrae said we've gone an entire
console generation without any splinter
cell announcement do you think we'll get
a bunch of ip revivals next gen likes
point-of-sale perfect dark conquer
it depends who they come from splinter
cell is an issue because it's ubisoft
ubisoft we have seen still actually do
incorporate a lot of stealth gameplay
into their games but have branched away
from very strict stealth because that is
a limited audience they want the
broadest audience possible with the open
world games where you can buy
crafting items or whatever it is now so
they would have to fundamentally change
splinter cell to fit the current ubisoft
business model frankly i don't think you
want splinter cell as it would exist in
2020
or next generation i don't think you
want it i don't think you want
what ubisoft makes splinter cell as now
because and maybe they frankly don't
even want to do it because it would be
such a departure from the franchise for
them to
fit their current video game making
strategy into the splinter cell
mold they're a lot more focused on
things being
fun and having fast traversal and and
less about the stealth these days is
basically my point
when it comes to to um perfect dark yeah
i see that coming back
that's a different company though flame
war sucks
said other than more extreme like
stalking how do fans cross the line or
what warrants are hey you don't really
know
you like that meat chill out type of
reaction in person i feel like
very rarely do i have people be
inappropriate i think sometimes since
joining funhouse people
will say things that are really rude
because they see us do that to each
other
um but when it comes from a stranger
it's definitely jarring when you have
someone you
don't know treat you the way you treat
people that you know
quite well because they know you from
that online relationship it's definitely
a little bit weird and i know a lot of
people
uh who work at rooster teeth have had
that same problem where like someone you
don't know is like called you a [ __ ]
or a [ __ ] or something like that
because that's the dynamic they've seen
on camera
um which in in that case i don't think
is necessarily their fault they
they've just like got a a warped view of
your relationship
one thing that specifically annoys me um
which annoys me for a very strange
reason again not even necessarily the
person's fault more my fault
is if someone comes up and asks me for a
photo but that's it they're just like
can i get a photo and then they put a
camera in front of your face and they
take it and they walk away i'm always
like say hi
who what's your name who are you well to
have a chat
if you just walk up and take a photo
it's it's this odd dynamic
that it creates which generally i think
people are doing that to save
time because they feel like i might be
in a rush generally if someone meets me
it's like at an event
very common in e3 or something like that
but i would wait prefer uh hey
nice to meet you i know you from this
can i get a picture then someone to just
take one and walk away
brianal nunley said how did you come up
with the name for your podcast red lips
orange car by the way thank you for
always making my days better when i
watch your content
thank you i appreciate that thank you
for watching uh the name
of red lips orange car is totally not
that interesting um for anyone who
doesn't know that is my
it's like comedy storytelling
relationship
podcast just brought it back last month
um my co-host is ethan nestor who some
of you might know as crank gameplays
it generally involves going on
craigslist and finding a craigslist
misconnection or a reddit thread where
some like
crazy online person talk about crazy
relationship [ __ ] and discussing it it's
a lot of fun
the title just comes from a craigslist
headline i was on craigslist
looking for content for the show before
i had come up with a name for it
one of the titles was red lips orange
car it was a guy who was looking for a
woman with red lips driving an orange
car
it just stood out to me so that's what
it's called daniel jardine said my
question is basically how long do you
think funhouse has left because a lot of
people have left
jawspool lawrence bruce here's
the thing there is no time frame on how
long one house can last it could pretty
much last forever
um and i think that there's this weird
perception where
internet groups are concerned people
leave jobs all the time
um especially for everyone at funhouse
who was at inside gaming they've been
doing the same thing for a decade
uh changing at some point in that period
of time and not working with the same
people anymore is not an unusual
thing to do it's just that it sucks
because
the people who consume that content are
used to that particular dynamic with
that particular group of people
but i don't think that anyone leaving
after being in the same position
for that amount of time is unusual or
should be concerning
you wouldn't be concerned if your your
friend who's worked at a company for
five years decided that they wanted to
change for the most part
uh particularly when it comes to content
creation where there isn't like a
corporate hierarchy that you can move up
and become an executive
um rooster teeth as a company i don't
think really functions that way so
yeah people of course want change and uh
wanting change and wanting to do
something different or wanting to do
something for yourself is not indicative
of the fall
of an entire company as it wouldn't be
at any other company
death hater said what's a company that
you dislike or borderline despise and
why
listen i try not to talk about this on
the internet because i'm aware it's
controversial
but it's disney and it's because they
have such a monopoly over the
entertainment industry and i think their
influence on pop culture is pretty much
unvetted and it's very concerning
okay bye where is one said what the [ __ ]
are you doing you're beautiful and smart
you're playing video games have children
i would rather i would rather die and
that's it for this month everyone
uh hope you're all staying safe and as
happy as you can
and putting books in backpacks and
lifting them maybe if you need some
exercise
uh i wanted to say thank you to everyone
who's been watching play watch listen
we're having a ton of fun making that
show
it's been awesome but thank you for your
questions if you want to ask questions
for next month
leave them in the comments below and i
will check them out then uh i will see
you guys next time bye